I watched this great documentary once
called Hitman Hart
and was about Bret Hart and who was the
most famous Canadian in the world for a
while and he was a worldwide Wrestling
Federation wrestler you know and he was
a good guy and he came from this famous
family of wrestlers who all came from
Alberta I think there were seven
brothers who were wrestlers and seven
sisters and all the sisters married
wrestlers they were all offspring
children of Stu Hart who who was a
wrestling impresario like 40 years ago
and it was it was such a cool
documentary because I was always
wondering why in the world do people
watch wrestling and and then believe it
you know
believe it do you believe movies when
you go watch them it's like that's a
hard question to answer while you're
there you do and so if you're watching
wrestling and you're a wrestling fan do
you believe it well it is a matter of
belief it's a matter of being engaged in
a drama and there are different levels
of drama right so let's say worldwide
Wrestling Federation drama is not the
most sophisticated form of drama okay
but our not being a not being a smart
aleck when I'm saying that there is
drama of different sophistication for
different people and that's also why
religious truths exist at multiple
levels simultaneously right there's got
to be something in it for everyone and
that's a hard belief system that's a
hard system to put together something
for the unbelievably sophisticated and
something for the common person
okay so we have wrestling and Bret Hart
was a good guy he fell into the
archetype of being a good guy and that's
partly what the what the story's about
it was a bit too much for him but one of
the things that he he laid out so
carefully was because he figured that a
hundred and twenty million people knew
him something like that and that
everywhere he went he was treated like a
hero and he found that quite a bit of
quite a burden and as you could imagine
if you think about it but he portrayed
what was happening in the wrestling ring
as classic good against evil but not
conceptualized and discussed right
embodied thought out acted out you know
like like the like Thor and the Hulk
except like right in front of you and so
well that's exactly this sort of thing I
mean we could consider hockey more
sophisticated than wrestling perhaps
and as I said I'm not being a critic of
these I'm not being critically minded
about these things I understand their
purpose and I would highly recommend
that documentary it's a brilliant
documentary but this is it's the same
thing it's a silver cup right it's like
there's the hero of the team that's the
hero of the teams you know here's
something cool if you're the fan of the
Toronto Blue Jays are the Toronto Maple
Leafs of course this hardly ever happens
to you if you're the fan of the Toronto
Maple Leafs because they always lose but
haha but but if you're watching a game
and your team wins and we take your
testosterone levels then they went up
and if you watch the Toronto Maple Leafs
and they lost and you're a fan then your
testosterone levels go down so that's
pretty damn funny you know I mean really
know you see how deeply instantiated
this is in people I mean it bloody well
alters your biochemistry like your your
your testosterone levels it's all more
my team loss you know it's like ah do we
know there'll be nothing in it for the
wife tonight you know so yeah